let's take a look at our GDP equation
for an open economy so GDP is equal to
national income and that's going to be
equal to consumption plus investment
plus government spending and since this
is an open economy plus net exports now
the first thing I want to do is let's
solve for net exports so I'm going to
subtract all of this stuff from both
sides so I could get national income
minus consumption
- government spending - investment is
equal to net exports this is just a
manipulation of what we just saw now
what is national income minus
consumption - government spending well
this right over here is national savings
this is s so another way we can think
about it is national savings
- investment is equal to net exports so
let's use this to think about capital
flows so first of all let's just make
sure we know what a capital flow is so
let's think about a capital inflow what
does that mean that means that
foreigners are taking capital and taking
it into our country to buy assets in our
country and an outflow that means that
residents of our country are taking
capital out of the country and buying
foreign assets and so do you think our
savings minus our investment is going to
be a capital inflow or capital outflow
well we've saved a bunch of stuff and we
are spending some of it on investment
and so what do we do with the rest of it
well it's gonna have to go outside of
the country because if it was being
invested inside the country it would be
in this I right over here and so this is
a net capital capital outflow and you'll
sometimes see this abbreviated and see
oh and so that sets up the identity that
net capital outflows are equal to net
exports let me just write it again for
emphasis net capital outflows are equal
to net exports now why does this make
sense
let's say net exports are positive that
means more foreigners are buying our
goods than we are buying their goods now
how are they going to pay for those
goods well they're going to have to pay
for those Goods and we're not going to
go into the details of currency exchange
and all that but one way to think about
how they pay for those goods is that
they need to sell their foreign assets
to folks in our country so if it's folks
in our country who are buying foreign
assets so that the foreigners can buy
our goods that would be a net capital
outflow from our point of view so
hopefully that makes intuitive sense now
another way to think about this is we
could rearrange this equation where if
we subtract net exports from both sides
and an add investment to both sides we
could get national savings minus net
exports minus net exports is equal to
investment now if net exports is equal
to net capital outflows what would be
the negative of net exports B well this
would be net capital inflows so we could
set up another equation and these are
all fairly straightforward algebra but
they give us a little bit of intuition
of how to think about these different
levers so we could say savings plus I'll
write the word out net capital inflow is
equal to investment is equal to
investment and think about why this
makes sense if we're if we have
investment in our country maybe we're
building factories we're building roads
where is the capital for that investment
coming it's either coming from domestic
savings national savings right over here
or it's coming from foreigners bringing
capital into our country which can be
used for investment so I will leave you
there the big takeaway is is we can just
manipulate the GDP equation for an open
economy here to get to this notion that
net capital outflows are equal to net
exports or that the negative of net
exports which would be net imports is
equal to net capital inflows and
hopefully this makes some intuitive
sense